hi i'm kitty green i'm the writer
director
co-editor and producer of the assistant
hi i'm julia garner and i am the actress
in the assistant and i play jane
and we're going to talk about the hr
scene where jane visits
her office company's hr representative
it's
a 12-page scene it's 12 pages of
dialogue and i
remember being very daunted going into
it because it was something that i
hadn't tackled that much
material before i guess in in a day so
um yeah how did you feel julia do you
remember what it was like for you
i was really nervous uh because i feel
like
when we we everything was kind of
leading up
to that day and that scene and
everything that we talked about even
weeks ahead
everything all the little scenes were
leading up to that
big scene um so it was super
intimidating but at the same time it was
super exciting
um you know it's just it was exciting in
the sense where it like could have gone
like really good or like
really bad the only thing that i felt
really good about was that we
worked so much around it like we we
really prepared for it
um and on the day
that's what i love i love shooting
really long scenes
because it it feels like a play you know
it's like it's
you know you you just you can't get out
of the moment in a way and we didn't
really
cut like we did from beginning to end
like almost pretty much every time
yeah how do you prepare like how do you
learn that many
like how do you prepare i don't
understand your process like what do you
like how do you remember all that
um i don't i'm like i don't know uh
you know i you just need to get
everything
ahead of time i feel like and then you
need to prioritize like what scenes
are closer to like what days like you're
shooting
closer to like the days of shooting it
um
but i feel like a lot of it is also not
just
line wise to prepare but also just
emotionally you know planning out every
beat
um every line especially with the hr
scene especially that scene had like a
different
uh there was different subtext behind
their behind every line
um that like one hand she was speaking
but the
like really being open but the other
hand
she wasn't fully being open because you
know she was obviously uh
she picked up quickly that she couldn't
be really honest
with matthew matthew's character in the
hr
um matthew is amazing let's
matthew is amazing how did you like
cast matthew or think about matthew i
mean i've been a fan of
his forever but like what did you think
of
uh matthew it's interesting like he i
mean i was a fan of his from his kind of
british
films pride and prejudice
a lot of people are making that
comparison between his character and
succession and this
and this character i think his
characters and those i think
him and the assistant and him in
succession are completely different you
just think maybe it's the same because
it's an office
yeah an american accent maybe two
something but like
we were looking i mean honestly the
first draft the character was really
mean
and really angry and swore a lot and it
was a lot of kind of bluster
and like force and it felt as i was
kept kind of drafting it and kept
figuring out what it would be
it kind of felt more insidious the more
kind of calm and rational and reasonable
he was
um you know this idea that he kind of
bring her in like trying to like kind of
using his charm and
sort of smiles and encouragement to kind
of reel her in before he kind of
goes in for the kill essentially so i
that his name came up and i thought oh
that would be wonderful and so we
it was kind of a no-brainer as soon as
somebody brought him up as an idea it's
just like oh he would be perfect
and he sort of got that ability to play
kind of something really evil
really creepy but also very charming
very you know
very handsome very likable yeah
you know and i think that's what makes
the hr
very conflicting is
is that you have somebody that is like
like the h
man who's playing you know the hr guy
like he is likable and you're kind of
like
but at the same time you're just like oh
he's so dismissive you know it's like so
painful
to watch i mean it was painful to
experience
like there was a certain point when we
were shooting that scene
where i was like this is an awful
feeling
it's awful you know that's the hardest
part of you know i guess being an actor
is like
you start really feeling all of like all
those feelings are
like even though i'm not jane but all my
emotions
are mine and i'm using that for the
characters that i'm playing so
i was feeling like that you know when
that hr
scene was happening and it was horrible
it was horrible
um yeah but you know it's a really
well written scene so
i mean you guys were so good i must say
we were i think we designed it so we
would shoot it in blocks like we cut it
up so we shoot like this section first
and this section first and then i think
on the first
take you're so good and you both just
kept
going and i didn't want to cut and i
think from then on we kept shooting the
thing in its entirety like the entire
kind of 12 minutes
and like i went was that tiring like it
was incredible for us we had well we had
a rehearsal a little bit before
remember that we talked about and that
was like the first time that i met
matthew so i was nervous about that but
we had a lot of time to talk
about this that day you know
weeks weeks ahead um but it was
it was building up i was like oh my god
i hope like all this
talk is gonna be like what i'm gonna do
is gonna be like
worth it but you know i wanted to ask
you
um the
you know because the writing you know
obviously
writing makes my job a little easier you
know when the writing is good and you
were saying oh how did you memorize
the lines and it's like well when the
writing is good it's much
easier to remember lines because the
dialogue is really good
you know that's how i always know when
dialogue's really good what was the
writing process for that scene and just
the writing
process in general with the moo the
whole
uh movie that you know everything was
building building building and just that
one scene did you feel like there was a
lot of pressure
with that one scene because everything
it was almost like a silent
movie and like everything kind of it was
boiling down to that one scene
yeah i mean there's not a lot of
dialogue in any of the other scenes
really so i remember this was a very i
mean it was
it felt unique in the screenplay in that
it was this kind of
a big page count and it was very
different into the way it was kind of
written and also so then
it kind of gave us an opportunity when
we were shooting it to be a little
unique formally like we kind of
changed the sort of visual style i guess
it kind of broke with the visual style
for that scene and kind of let the two
of you lead it and it became kind of
more performance driven than
say visually stylistic in some senses
but um
i think writing it was interesting it
was something where i was chatting to a
lot of young women in the research phase
of this film who worked
at different companies a lot of women
from production companies but also from
other
industries like tech and engineering and
things like that who
spoke to me about trying to speak up
about their workplaces about
the bad behavior about sort of toxic um
you know work environments um and
finding they were shut down by their hr
department and this
so i was specifically looking to put in
something about the fact that the hr
department is there to protect the
company and not the employees
and so his job was to protect his boss
and he's just doing his job in that
scene which is
even more terrifying um but also to use
it as an example of
gaslighting i mean he she comes in with
some idea about what's happened she's
sort of boiled over at this point it's
been kind of brewing and like she's
her tension is kind of building
throughout that entire first
sort of 40 minutes of the movie and this
is the point where she kind of it kind
of boils over and she's ready to say
like you know speak her mind and she's
just he just
makes her doubt herself confused she
leaves rattled confused she doesn't even
know if
she feels worse she feels actually worse
when she came
in and like she feels worse when she got
out instead of like when she came in
exactly she's like that's how i felt
when when i was shooting the project
was it uh you know obviously like with
writing
was it after that scene
that you wrote the hr scene did you feel
that you know going like you felt
uh worse going out writing after that
scene and then writing the scene
after it like what was the process like
did you feel more alone
and isolated because already writing is
such an isolating
feeling like how did you feel after um
i feel like that scene was never i
almost wrote the entire movie and then
had that as like a placeholder and said
like hr
scene you know where she goes she knows
she brings up the way i describe it is
like she's got the dots but she can't
join them she can't like join the dots
essentially she can't prove
that she's seen anything she doesn't
have any kind of evidence essentially so
um i knew that that what i wanted to
happen and that seemed it was the last
thing to write so i wrote everything
else
and then kind of figured out over a few
weeks i think it was actually christmas
a couple years ago where i figured out
like kind of how that would play i'm
gonna took just a lot of different like
playing around with different styles
figuring out who he was
how kind of it's his charm
and how insidious it was that he is kind
of asking you about your dreams and
hopes and kind of
using your career ambition against you
going well if you want this
you know you're throwing it all away by
being here you know it's kind of
really insidious and really devastating
seeing her
yeah yeah um
yeah yeah anyway it was a bit
yeah the process wasn't that diff it was
kind of just figuring out and there's a
few like moments i call like punctuation
moments like when he takes that call
he knows at the point that you have not
you don't have enough evidence that you
don't have anything on him
so he can kind of laugh about the ranges
on the phone and then there's the tissue
box moment which is just so horrific
that i don't remember was that kind of
that was scripted but it became
like when we were shooting it became
more of a moment
when we were shooting i feel like right
that steel tissue box was so loud
and i think there was one take where
matthew like it was
it was really loud so it was just like
and then all of a sudden it was like
like is he really giving me a tissue
like i i don't want it it felt like i
remember shooting it it felt like
i don't want to take anything from this
man like
i don't even want to take a tissue that
he's offering
even though i really want to take it
because like i am
crying you know crying a river right now
but it's also so demeaning i think you
actually weren't crying with the point
he pushes it too late you know
yeah well yeah or something just like
he's like oh
the woman is crying
but yeah i think yeah it was
those those kind of see those kind of
moments help the edit as well in terms
of a flow of
it's a very long scene and it was able
to kind of it kind of reboots
um i think at those two points and and
you guys are incredible so
yeah that helps a lot too was there a
lot of
like scenes to um
you know because there was such a long
take takes uh was it really hard to
cut around it or was it just kind of
easier i mean i don't know anything
about editing and obviously like you
have your background is a documentary
and i always say like
a really great documentary filmmak like
filmmaker or editor is like almost like
it's like a film
you know editing is so important in
documentary i feel like
so how was it at that scene
it was pretty i mean it wasn't difficult
to cut because the performances were so
good like you two were so incredible
that i mean my biggest problem was every
time i would watch the footage i would
just get lost in it just watching your
fae and i would
forget kind of where i should put the
edit points and because i'd just
be sort of transported by what was going
on which
was incredible um but yeah i mean
there's a lot going on
on your face which i wanted to chat with
you about because it is that kind of
struggle of like
all the things she's holding back she
can't say i mean it's an office
environment so she's not gonna
scream and yell and cry so that kind of
internal struggle to me was really
interesting and me trying to get that
right so that
we did your performance justice where we
used the right takes and we kind of
cut it together in a way that made that
you know gave that trajectory that
emotional trajectory kind of resonance
um
yeah i wanted to ask you about that how
you felt about that character like that
how you play that i i remember when we
first met up like
you said you really wanted it to be a
quiet
film the whole thing not just like on
the page but just the whole feel of it
like
not even much music and and have just
the
tension being so loud um
and i totally agreed with that because
everything was in that hr
scene that needed to be said and if
everything else was quiet that hr scene
was going to be
even louder in a way um
and i you know really isolating the
uh audience isolating
separating the audience and separating
the people around
jane i really wanted to keep it separate
so like
the audience was almost like how jane
felt it or her feelings in a way and
that
it was only like from jane's perspective
and kind of going with what you were
saying just having it be a really quiet
film and not
just keeping so they felt isolated too i
just wanted
i felt like it would be really powerful
to have the
um movie just be a really isolating
experience for everyone that like even
though people
were sitting in the movie theater i
wanted like together i wanted them to
like feel isolated even from each other
even if they were
you know and i mean just that whole
isolating ex
experience um
but yeah i guess it's
um you know and i guess with the hr
scene i think too like you know
us working on the different subtexts of
every line behind every line there's a
different subtext
i think that's where subtext is so
important
because i could say something that's
written on the page
but really i really want to say
something else
but i just don't know how and that's
where subtext
is so handy and so important with a
scene like that because she might be i
might be saying something to matthew's
character
but really the subtext there is some
there's a line behind
the line and i'm not saying it so
you always feel like you're wanting more
from that character you're like you're
like on the edge of your seat in a way
like why isn't she
there's something else you know and that
makes it even more heartbreaking when he
does gaslight her
because she's not she doesn't know how
to articulate what she's truly thinking
yeah yeah and there's that kind of
relationship with you and
christine's character like this
waitress who comes in and this idea but
you're saying she's a waitress and he's
accusing you of woman was not respecting
her enough like what you don't you think
she doesn't have enough experience
because she's a way to like
or just you know making it that you're
you're just
you're just uh are you jealous at her
that sounds
another thing and then you know she
probably double things like
maybe i am jealous of her and i wasn't
even aware of it
so it's not just that one thing like oh
yeah i was really worried about her i
mean it's it's
so many different things you know
it's that's where like again subtext
like you know and that's what
the scene had it made it so much easier
like
the writing was so good it just made it
easy
to pick like a a subtext in a way like
work around that yeah i mean you were
such a pleasure to work with
it was so wonderful so thank you so much
for being a part of this film it's been
such a wonderful experience thank you so
much
and you know how much i love you and um
like i'm just i'm just waiting for the
next thing
we'll do together you know like we'll
know each other for a long time
so i would love yes yes
thank you for watching this um
i hope that you enjoy it as much as we
enjoyed making
this film